after nearly two weeks of gripes goodbye
Brenda Snipes she resigns after the
Florida Senate race ends meanwhile
Stacey Abraham Abrams asked these
self-obsessed snobs of Hollywood not to
boycott Georgia because she lost yep
some stars have threatened to boycott
the state because the vote that made
Bryant Kemp the winner still stands Ron
Perelman Alyssa Milano Bradley Whitford
Georgia's really gonna miss you guys so
now we know how to keep pompous
Hollywood crybabies out of our state win
elections this is a better incentive
than lower taxes and safer streets a
vote for a Republican means alec baldwin
won't punch locals in the face a vote
against the leftist means you'll never
run into Jim Carrey weeping in the park
but clearly this is another tantrum
disguised as a principled stand it's
easy to boycott something you don't need
something tells me Ms Milano or mr.
Perlman didn't have lucrative projects
lined up in Savannah it's pure
destructive selfishness let's push
boycotts that don't affect me but harms
the economy that sports millions of
middle-class Americans hell I'll just
stay in bel-air the royalties from full
hell house will pay for my bean paste
facials and I still get to virtue signal
on Twitter boycotting a state is an even
sadder version of I'm moving to Canada
because even if they sneak into Georgia
they never move to Canada but what's
great it's far easier to boycott a body
of work than a body of land everyone can
do it and once ELISA or Bradford star in
anything beyond a tweet Georgians can
exercise their rights too
all right well there's no there's how
can we not please you guys you guys got
you basically did get a blue wave let's
face it close to 40 seats should be
happy yeah I mean I would be happy but
they're still like mad they're gonna
boycott Georgia
let me see you mister miss Chris was his
interview with Donald Trump I was I was
out drinking I was coming home but the
president said he won he said that he
won the Senate that's what countin when
Chris said would about the house and he
could lose like 36 seats he's an odd all
right you didn't hear me we won we won
the Senate but when you I mean he's
being
being an optimist but on the other side
the Democrats are still mad they're
still angry even winning that many seats
and nobody readership 7/7 governorship
is confusing what happened in Georgia it
wasn't that the Senate seat in Georgia I
don't think it was an issue I think yet
the governor yes gubernatorial yeah and
there you see Stacey Abrams saying that
Brian Kemp who was also Secretary of
State somehow managed to push people out
you know what I'm saying is you can't
win them all so don't be a sore loser
that's all I'm saying oh well I think
that's kind of dirty tactics but I'll
leave the rest okay all right Jesse I
just like in the monologue you admitted
that you to get facials yeah I usually
go a pumpkin spice facial the same the
one I haven't tried yet but it was it
would do you well first of all are you
gonna miss miss Snipes sneaky yeah
she retired I know but I'm sure what
she'll pop up somewhere on my feed I
will miss her dearly but I think reg I
think Democrats always expect to win for
a few reasons one they live in a bubble
a social bubble and a media bubble -
they think controlling government is
their rightful destiny because they
believe they're progressives and it's
progress and also they believe their
whole governing philosophy is about
controlling government that they're
supposed to be in charge and then
Democrats believe this is life and death
good versus evil so when they lose I
mean it is a soul-crushing loss that's
why they have to question each loss and
say well it's illegitimate it's like
therapy for them in fact most
Republicans when they win Democrats
don't think they're legitimate at all I
mean if you think then you go back look
at Bush in 2000 look at Trump in 2016
look at all the Scott Walker elections
they questioned his legitimacy look you
have Kemp now DeSantis and Scott and
every single time there's an excuse from
Democrats it's gerrymandering it's
racism sexism it's the Russians
it's voter suppression that Hillary
Clinton and what sixty excuses for her
loss so in the grand scheme of things
you look at Florida and you think in the
last couple elections there you've had
tons
of shenanigans by people like sneaky
Snipes ballots were destroyed ballots
were miscounted they found ballots
things are done in the secret and now
judges have to come in and say guys
knock it off and Republicans say you
know things are getting fishy that this
could be some kind of fraud taking place
and then Republicans are cast as
conspiracy theorists how dare you
question an election you're not allowed
to do that but if you look at the poll
Economist poll said 67 percent of
Democrats 67 percent believe that
Russians tampered with votes that's who
elect Donald Trump in 2016 now that's
just false votes were never tampered
with yet two-thirds of Democrats believe
in that conspiracy could I not not
helping that is this is an interview
Jake Tapper did with miss Abrams about
the legitimacy of the election do you
think that there was deliberate
interference in the election yes and I
believe it began eight years ago with
the systematic disenfranchisement of
more than a million voters is he the
legitimate governor-elect of Georgia he
is the person who won an adequate number
of votes but that's not I'm the governor
you're not using the word legitimate is
he the legitimate governor-elect of
Georgia he is the legal governor of
Georgia God what do you think Dana I
think a couple of things like I read
that the Weekly Standard editorial today
talking about these claims about that
she's making and they were happy says
we're happening in Georgia but if you go
through them one by one they're talking
about people who were purged off of the
rolls right that's like if that was 1.5
million but why does it why was it so
many those people that died people that
moved people and there was a lawsuit in
2015 that meant that nobody came off the
rolls that year so this is the first
year that you see it so it looks like
it's double and I didn't know that until
I read know that until you read this is
what's great about Dana is I didn't have
to read that article or subscriber I do
think
the the president and others were
calling we're saying that there was
voter fraud in Florida and maybe in
Georgia too that was a suggestion the
Democrats are saying there's voter
suppression neither are presenting
adequate evidence right sir and so I
don't know what happens going forward I
do think about somebody like a Brenda
Snipes we can make fun of her or
whatever and it looks like some
incompetence but she gets it done in the
end now she's retiring but you think
about who who's willing to serve their
communities these public servants and
like we have to figure out a way to
support them and to provide them with
what they need and the resources that
they need or we have to go to the robot
the robots I say the robots Katie
they'll take care of all of this you see
the robot anchor that came out in China
oh yes a lot like you guys thank you
I'll take that as a compliment I'm very
smooth you are very smooth that's true
it's official yes but there are
legitimate questions about what happened
maybe in Georgia but also in Florida in
in terms of the voter rolls not being
cleaned up Brenda Snipes got sued also
for having people were who are 114 years
old on her her goals for people who had
you know left the county all those
things and so the follow-up has to be
not just one of appointing someone new
but the secretary of state office
especially in Florida for Broward and
Palm Beach counties and in pushing them
to say okay 2020 is coming this type of
behavior actually does undermine
democracy as we always hear about so we
have to make sure that things are
cleaned up for the presidential election
so it doesn't come down to two counties
that have repeatedly had problems for a
decade making these determinations and
and questions about where the ballots
were found and why they're being
transported in private vehicles and that
kind I said one other thing though about
Stacey Abrams
so she did something pretty pretty
remarkable she's a progressive liberal
mm-hmm and she came pretty close in
Georgia yeah so it's like George George
is not gonna change overnight yeah but
she said she wants to run again so can
she figure out a way like to figure how
can she make up those 60,000 votes or
whatever it is I can she find 60,000
votes she could become the legitimate
wish and she did a nice thing where she
said she said boycotting Georgia is
stupid don't do it I mean she didn't
encourage that sort of baby
have a runoff I think for Secretary of
State in Georgia and I think that's
really important because I you know even
Jimmy Carter I guess that doesn't mean
much with you guys but Jimmy I love
Jimmy the former president said camp
should have never been in charge of the
election in which he was competing what
Dana said about Stacey Abrams I think
she undermines her own case when she's
not willing to just accept the results
with class and move on because she does
deserve a lot of credit for the job that
she did there and by her saying it was
stolen or that these things happen she
actually deal ajith amaizing all of the
hard work she put in and the votes that
she got well I would like to add at the
end of this segment that this might be
the last recount segment we do in two
years that great you still have the
caravan we do have the caravan three
segments on the caravan Jessa